this dance troupe from Tanzania is but a
sampling of the youthful passion and
promise in the world's least developed
countries
nearly three-quarters of them live on
the continent of Africa this is the
greatest
Innovative
uh you know knowledge hungry generation
that's the biggest potential but we have
natural resources but are being
exploited by others it is not dependent
on somebody else to come and do what we
need to do let them become partners
in development for real while we set the
vision and they help us fulfill it
from the Solomon Islands to South Sudan
and Haiti this week the UN Spotlight has
been on the world's poorest people
the once in a decade U.N conference on
the least developed countries in Doha
has been touted as a quote momentous
occasion to implement a path forward of
progress a lot of the least developed
countries have quite a low level of
Revenue domestic revenues compared to
GDP there's a lot of potential there for
them to find more resources and what the
IMF does are our teams provide a lot of
capacity building help the Doha program
of action is a road map for the next
eight years its main components include
eradicating poverty enhancing
international trade and combating
climate change and online university and
an investment support center are also
part of the plan
with only 19 percent of women and girls
in these countries connected to the
internet leaders say gender equality is
vital we need to focus on closing the
gap between men and women in Technology
Innovation and science if we don't it
will be hard to reach gender equality
the UN hopes this week the world has
revived a commitment to transform the
potential of the more than one billion
most vulnerable people into prosperity
Natasha ganang Al Jazeera Doha